cominciamo bene a tutti i ragazzi mi
avete nessun video sono faringei qua c'è
sabrina che mi accompagna in questa
vettura incredibile chiamata il sim 4
siccome eravamo rimasti che selena è
incinta e il grande carlo messicano
vogliamo ampliare la famiglia ma siccome
nei commenti avete tutti tutti butti
chiesto di aggiungere il mio cane tra la
famiglia wow non avrei mai detto
fortunatamente abbiamo le stazioni per i
cani gatti insomma gli animali niente
creiamo il cane il mio cane quindi
andiamo a mettere summer sì ma perché
hai messo la spazzatura fuori di casa
non si fa così ma non si fa lo faccio
così allora visto quando sei entrato in
casa mia c'e la spazzatura fuori una
stanza dei cani dove la vogliamo fare
abbastanza del cane va fatta alla
ragazza la lettiera il gatto potremmo
fare una cosa così e sera facciamo una
bella stanza cuore è lui a cui
costruirla certo per esempio o vuoi fare
un astante la madonna de vivo in una
casa più grossa dalla nostra sì sì in
cane è un cane ma in quel tuo cane
capitolo elkann i favi gay che rigo
bravi fatto apposta
che roba allora ascolta me li vogliamo
far l'agility non so cosa sia la gerit
ma facciamolo agility percorsi dei cani
percorsi dei cani dentro caso ben fatto
ci ha messo anche le tende giusto perché
prendere il tuo cane superfigo ecco la
quale abbiamo quello per farlo saltare
cerchio alto cerchi medio o cerchio
basso cerchio ma gas folino ok potremo
fare cerchio basso
poi abbiamo lo slalom ma veramente lì si
fa tutto il percorso
ecco scende la rampa vacua e la
postazione né finale
elenchiamo qua mi sembra molto carino no
tanto i cani vendono sono in bianco e
nero che bello da è bellissimo mi piace
è veramente figo il pavimento molto qua
io pavimenti per questo ho sempre messo
no no no no per i cani devi mettere
questo qua trovi loro leader che se non
vuoi metterli parquet chiaro oppure
guarda sai cosa può mettere vediamo suo
trovo l'ombrello rosso era bello radio
blu la strada dei cani è fatta abbiamo
speso 800euro per il cane un milione e
800 euro per la stanza mi sembra
corretto ragazzi andiamo a fare il capo
è stato c'è l'adesivo del canelli uno
solo uno solo che tanto era quello
giusto rimandare a creare il cane
troviamo il cagnolino allora ci sono e
razze lo aspetta lui poi sistemare e
puoi scegliere quanto è grande e quindi
vai mattino 4was esatto dopo mentre
cucciolo già vede 19 cucciolo lo è
attualmente quindi mortai tagliano
sistemarlo però perché aspettare un po
troppo riccione questo allora la coda
come ce l'ha così così
ok poi il pelo cela corto
no quello di prima ce l'ha così da
salotto o il colore del manto colore del
mento e il man u manto esatto esatto
sono pelourinho qua e poi dipingi ce
l'ha
i suoi di dipingere mio cane si facciamo
molto simile porca vacca un aspetto
altro ne approfitto per farvi vedere
questo carino e incredibile che terra
cucchia due zampe dobbiamo bian carlon
qua è ok è tutto bianco amore tenero una
palla e tenero che aspettano sbagliato
vorrei le orecchie sicilia marroni
esatto che è perfetto ci siamo il mio
cane san pietroburgo siamo sia m bordo
allora scegliamo ritratti non è
assordante prego 33 allora è scemo e
testardo hard aveva piccolo 15 passare
attivo o mio dio e verso pianta grave è
proprio il male sta falsità di pisa ca
fermo c'è un big errore guardo a sedere
sono già cacata addosso ma il tenero
esattamente così dai quali aspetti farci
vedere una foto di stamattina che ho
messo la già vista e alla vita faccio
vedere voi e così lei de e identico
identico esattamente come qua per
temporale entro dentro da ora che ti
guardano che puzzano di ripagarsi che è
tenero mi sta leccando entriamo deve
subito i bisogni da fare kakà kakà per
terra tranquillo mia moglie
selena a posto io sto pulendo ma se sta
piovendo cosa fu l'iscos asciugo per
terra e viola vita vera the sims sul
cervello ma il mio cane qua è mai
balcani e forse troppo piccolo non può
fare prova a premere qua incendia
no dai no ascolto ma c'è un mese mi ama
la città dove mangiare ce l'ha solo
cristiano
mettiamola così mette bravo e mi sto
imparando a tu per ciotola mangiatoia
per arimany amica programmatica sono 240
dollari di ciotola
perché la natura mamma mia ma andiamo
india
vediamo di mangiare bellocchio guerra
come mai c'è l'accesso ai più grossa di
lui guarda che mangia parole diventa un
rottweiler che lei entrata nel prossimo
trimestre però vedere un po terzo
trimestre quasi pronto per la fine
dell'esperienza nori quindi dice che
dobbiamo farla stanza adesso dovremo
fare una stanza per i pup fermi tutti
allora visto che io sono un padre
incredibilmente responsabile che tutto
il giorno si spacca la schiena guardami
qua facciamo la stanza del pup 8 allora
per i pupi la prima cosa che tu faresti
è la parete del gruppo di tutto maschi e
femmine scontenti pesce femmina termini
che meno ci facciamo tutto con la baby
bike immagini ma questo questo giocoso
per bambini da questo la stessa degli
occhi a questa è la stanza di giornata
va bene basta tutto ciò che vuole a casa
mia
più nella stanza vola a parte che più
grossa mano prego arena la stanza di
allora io per un pupo metterei un
violino castello delle bambole
principessa realistica per la vera di un
giorno non gioca col castello del
richiamo da principessa ho detto
principessa realistica poi farfalla de
farfalli bus 120 euro ripagata di
bambino giocattolo di panda lunare
guarda quanto piccolo 100 euro
attenzione e mobili per bambini
incredibile andiamo di sotto culla per
bambino dondola dormi dondola enormi e
speriamo che dormi 8.000 euro
rimandiamoli la curia ma quella sta
vicino alla luce poi andiamo sul
comodino cassettone per bambini bimbo
prodotti e lo mettiamo al posto di sto
cassettone bacio duna verde cia che era
mia moglie andiamo qua lo buttiamo
colloca ben di 20 20 chi se lo compra
non lo so i quadri i quadri per bambini
i quali per bambini si copiano un cane
io lo metterei un riporto al canale
si capisce da subito che ci sono degli
animali in casa questa l'ho vista anche
in live strange la mettiamo qua aspetta
sopra finestre figo 420 euro un battello
giocattolo ceci va in crociera con 420
euro compriamo tenda e direi un bel
tappeto giocoso riproduzione di rango di
aspirare i no non mi piace teoria
colorata no perché si confonde troppo
con quello che già c'è
direi di mettere a perché questo non si
confonde con quello che già c'è ma è
bellissimo
ho speso dei soldi inutilmente ma gli va
bene niente giocattoli stupidi tipo la
pa per palestrina per bella palestrina
dove è nato gesù
ma qual è la palestina io so neanche se
nota in palestina enorme ma posso
metterla fuori
ma perché non ha senso mamma mia che
bella stanza sapri che il vasino
propedeutico hop ed etico che lo
mettiamo qua perché mentre cadeva da
fare sarebbe quando tuo figlio nasce non
è abbastanza grandi da poter utilizzare
queste cose
andiamo vede racconto st mia moglie di
gravidanza al seggiolone mega per
mangiare di sotto lo mettiamo qua guarda
qua se giorno nei mega ci mettete qui va
bene la stanza per bambini ragazzi e
fatta sabrina volta da 1 a 10
e stato bello grazie per avermi invitato
in questa fantastica serie ti prego sta
benino bisogno di chiamare così se
abbiamo bisogno di tempo una guardia
familiare ha ricevuto
dai ragazzi deve partorire clicchiamo se
partorisce pavè ragazzi sabrina mi ha
abbandonato ma non perché non mi vuole
bene ma perché crede che io sia troppo
adatto a fare il genitore concludono
episodio qua ringrazio prima per avermi
accompagnato abbiamo preso samp creato
la stanza del pargolo e direi che nel
prossimo episodio siamo pronti per
completare la nostra famiglia composta
da me le moglie il piccolo sun e the bay
mi che non sappiamo se sia maschio
femmina ma sarà femmina perché se è
maschio è un bel problema visto che la
stanza
l'ho fatta per bambine quindi sarebbe un
bel problema però che vi sia piaciuto
come vi piace anche vari social comitato
dalla descrizione se bastano questi
schiavi e noi come sempre ci vediamo
hanno seguito da ragazzi
[Musica]